police in the thai capital are looking
for those responsible for the latest
attack on anti-government protesters
which injured dozens it's the third
attack after weeks of largely peaceful
protest one demonstrator was killed on
Friday and another seriously injured in
a shooting on saturday the guy who
attacked the producer that the mend of
the government the recent violence could
be a turning point because people would
rather be Patriots than be frightened
anti-government protesters continue to
rally around suit depth talks about the
firebrand protest leader has rallied
support by tapping into anger among
staunch loyalists and the urban middle
class at a government they consider
corrupt Sutekh's goal is to force Prime
Minister Yingluck Shinawatra and her
elected government from office and to
establish an unelected People's Council
to push through political reforms the
government accuses the opposition of
provoking violence in order to pave the
way for the army to intervene
demonstrators have taken control of
several key government buildings and
thank the police who do not bar their
way with roses